meanwhile back here in the valley this  is a live look at valley high school  where the jrotc is paying tribute in  front of a campus there to those lost on  9 11. that's right later in the morning  students are going to pause to remember  teacher barbara edwards she died in the  attack was on her way back from the east  coast a foreign language teacher she was  a palo verde high school teacher she was  on american airlines flight 77 which  crashed into the pentagon and lost her  life in the tragedy every year the ccsd  takes time out not only to honor those  who died all across  the the three different uh four  different locations  but also of course miss edwards so this  is taking place live at valley high  school we'll have much more on it coming  up through good day las vegas